hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga my name is liam and in honor
of hunter hunter i'm going to name my
firstborn beyond liam and today we're
here to talk about netero but like
better further beyond if you will
because our chairman may be long past
but his legacy still very much remains
in the series in the form of his old man
son beyond and my question is what is
beyond netro's nen affinity and at this
point you might be saying wait a minute
random guy on the internet we haven't
even seen beyond usenet at this point
how could you possibly suggest that you
know something i don't well you're right
we don't know for sure but we do have
enough information to make a solid
estimation because nen is about far more
than oral use it has more to do with
personality and drive and when it comes
to both of those we know plenty about
beyond and it's all going to begin with
a quick round of dark continent or dark
incontinence a very simple mini-game the
rules of which are as follows beyond has
found himself aboard a ship heading for
the dark continent however he has also
been struck with a terrible case of
incontinence and it's going to be your
job to guess which of these three
bathrooms beyond chooses to use now
should you guess incorrectly then your
punishment will be to form a binding
vowel by subscribing to the new world
review which will also result in
consistent injections of hunter-based
culture administered directly into your
youtube feed and if you are correct then
you will also be allowed to use the
bathroom but only after finishing this
video so which one will it be a b or the
third one make your choice now and we
shall reveal the answer in three two one
and bam it was bathroom b because
bathroom begins with a b the other two
contained dark continent creatures so if
you chose incorrectly then
good luck but you know the thing to do
and please do say hi in the comments
below if you are new to our association
welcome but onwards and beyond words
let's start with general analysis beyond
is actually quite rare in the series
because he has not displayed any menus
whatsoever outside of this one
promotional artwork that is takashi did
once draw beyond with what looks like
gaura surrounding his hand but it's
strictly promotional it's hard to know
what to read or even if we should read
into this so in terms of the actual
series canon beyond is quite a quiet
individual and what i mean by this is
that generally even characters that you
think haven't displayed nen have almost
certainly done so at a basic level
without you necessarily noticing and
paristan is a great example of this he's
never shown a nen ability however he has
been shown performing ren on several
occasions which you can only pick up on
in the manga through the assaulted voom
sound effects which togashi uses to
indicate a hostile use of aura however
when it comes to beyond he doesn't even
have that much going for him he
certainly has a commanding presence on
page but in terms of aura he can only be
labeled as silent which rather fittingly
is exactly how his father isaac was
described by xenozoldic zeno stated that
one of netro's strongest points was just
how quiet his aura was undetectable and
unreadable a quality that seems to have
been inherited by beyond so in this one
unique case a lack of aura display
actually makes me take him far more
seriously as we should because beyond is
of course a survivor of the dark
continent the only others that we really
know of being his father and potentially
up to two extremely overpowered hunters
and as his name not so subtly implies he
may very well be beyond the power of his
late father or at the very least he's in
the prime of his life whereas the isaac
netaro we know was in a state of decline
and the zodiacs do recognize this as
they assigned no less than three of them
to guard beyond aboard the blackwell one
although to be honest that's still
probably not enough but in terms of
beyond's direct affinity we have a bit
of an intriguing situation here because
we almost never encounter
multi-generational nen users in the
series the three examples we do have
being the zoltik family the freaks
family and now the netero family so
discerning his affinity might be as easy
as simple genetics isaac nataro was an
enhancer which means that according to
the very minimal data we have it makes
it slightly more likely that beyond is
also an enhancer although to be fair
this is pretty much based entirely on
the zoldic family example then an
affinities follow a very clear set of
genetics all of the zoldic children have
either inherited the affinity of their
mother kikio a manipulator or their
father silva a transmuter and
furthermore silva looks to have
inherited transmutation directly from
his father zeno so there is a clear
through line there but even if we do
take genetics seriously from our one
example the idea of beyond's unknown
mother ensures that we can't just sit
back and label him as an enhancer simply
because of his father so that means we
need to consult our morally questionable
oracle hisoka because this magical clown
man has invented his own system of
determining an affinities without even
witnessing a single drop of aura it's
rather cutely labeled as the hisohiso or
based personality analysis and it's a
startlingly accurate system even though
hisoka himself states that it's no more
accurate than trying to judge someone by
their star sign he is being modest it's
correct on i would say about 90 of
occasions so given that we were just
talking about enhancement let's begin
there hisoka's criteria for an enhancer
is someone who is simple and determined
they're very straightforward never hide
things and do not lie they're incredibly
selfish and goal oriented plus their
simplicity is reflected in their net
abilities and based on this i think that
enhancement isn't the greatest of fits
for beyond mostly because he is far from
simple and he's hidden literally
everything about himself since his
introduction and he almost certainly
lies like he lies a lot with that said i
should note that even isaac nestoroid
doesn't fit this description perfectly
or perhaps even at all i mean in many
ways he was a very simple man with a
simple goal and a selfish one at that
but he did certainly hide quite a bit
and to be fair beyond may have been very
sneaky with the kakin empire and the
hunter association but he has always
been quite blunt about his goal of
returning to the dark continent so
enhancement now it doesn't sound like
the perfect fit but i definitely
wouldn't exclude it entirely next up we
have transmutation which according to
hisoka presents very much the opposite
of enhancers transmuters are whimsical
fickle and prone to deceit they hold
unique attitudes and are regarded by
others as tricksters and weirdos which
is fun because this is hisoka describing
himself as a weirdo actually transmute
is often put up facades and even if they
don't hide their personalities they do
hide their intentions and this last part
is probably the most applicable to
beyond his true personality is on proud
display at all times however his
intentions are completely shrouded
nobody knows why he wants to go to the
dark continent just that he very loudly
does want to the problem here is that i
would never call beyond whimsical or
fickle because remember that beyond has
been planning this dark continent
excursion for roughly half a century now
that takes some pretty extreme
dedication and focus and it's definitely
not like a hisoka situation where he
gets distracted every two seconds by a
new erection so i don't think transmuter
is a great fit either moving on to a
mission then according to hisoka natural
emitters are impatient not
detail-oriented short-tempered and
volatile and we're going to stop right
here because this is probably the worst
match so far not a single one of those
english words can apply to beyond this
man has been patiently planning a
heavily detail-oriented plot with a calm
demeanor for the last 50 years there is
no personality trait present in an
emitter that suggests that beyond could
even be in consideration for it however
this is one of those potentially
unreliable situations because there are
emitters which go against the grain as
well razer for example who is the poster
boy for a mission and it may well be
because of meeting jing but he is
incredibly patient and attentive to
details as a game master of greed island
paying attention to details are quite
literally his entire job he's very much
the exception that proves the rule
though most natural emitters do fit this
description really well like say la oreo
or knuckle so i'm going to be bold and
say that beyond is almost certainly not
an emitter at least not according to
hisoka's crazy system which brings us to
conjuration allegedly conjurers are
highly strong stoic serious dude guys
and gals and i guess non-binary and they
tend to be quite nervous and always on
guard whilst remaining observant and
cognizant of falling into traps despite
that nervous energy though the trademark
trait for condra is the ability to
perform calm analysis under almost any
situation and that last part right there
is the only reason why we're not
completely dismissing conjuration as a
man whose most famous sign is i will
wait no matter how long it takes beyond
brings new definition to the word khan
but i definitely would not call him
overly serious and especially not highly
strong in fact he very much takes after
his father and appears to take great
enjoyment out of everything that life
has to offer even in exceptionally
dangerous circumstances so it's another
meh one but surely after so many meh
ones we are getting closer to the
perfect fit so let's try manipulation
manipulators are argumentative and
logical they advance at their own pace
and have a desire to keep their families
and or loved ones safe however when it
comes to pursuing their own goals they
do not listen to others and it is
simultaneously so perfect and yet so not
perfect beyond can definitely be saddled
with the descriptors of argumentative
and logical you may have a lot of flair
whilst doing so but logic is definitely
king with beyond plus he does have a
huge degree of demonstrated respect for
his father he even quotes isaac during
his introduction by saying my beloved
father always used to say when you stop
challenging yourself your life is over
however this was a public address and he
might just be using the reputation of
the former chairman to advance his own
agenda which by the way though would be
a stunning indicator of a manipulator
because whether that's his affinity or
not beyond is a master of political
manipulation i mean just due to his
actions alone an entire nation and a
massive chunk of the hunter association
and now on route to the dark continents
he's got some skills to pay those
manipulator bills however the problem is
with the second part when it comes to
the goals of manipulators apparently
they don't listen to those around them
and that is demonstrably untrue with
beyond because isaac natural forbade his
son from revisiting the dark continent
until after his death and beyond seems
to have listened to his father he made
good on that command so it's really
tricky personally i think that
manipulation is the best fitting
affinity so far especially with the
advance at your own pace mentality but
there is a pretty stark flaw so let's
see what specialization has to offer us
specialists are independent and
charismatic they won't say anything
important about themselves and refrain
from forming close relationships however
their natural charisma draws others and
they are often surrounded by many people
and ding ding ding it may not be quite
as specific as hisoka's previous
definitions but everything about
specialization fits beyond perfectly he
is absurdly charismatic and despite
being alone actor he is always
surrounded by people in fact he's
surrounded by an entire empire currently
so according to hisoka specialization
would be beyond's best fit however we do
have another system which is furykov's
criteria of affinity analysis via
witnessing the ten of others and sadly
since we have not witnessed the ten of
beyond there's only so much we can do
here however there is one very relevant
aspect to examine which is furykov's
definition of enhancers and transmuters
according to him they have a very soft
quiet ten which does play very well with
the idea of beyond's extremely quiet
aura in general although if we were to
take takashi's promo artwork into
account then beyond may also fit
furykov's conjuration definition which
is having a strong aura surrounding a
dominant part of their body with a
gentle flow everywhere else and this
image definitely contains a strong
dominant flow within that very handy
sector so what is beyond's net affinity
well something we can exclude
immediately is a mission there isn't a
single piece of evidence that makes that
path worthy of consideration and despite
the aforementioned statement about
conjuration that also feels equally as
unlikely there are just too many clashes
of personality traits and i'm not going
to place any bets based on promo artwork
i'm also going to eliminate
transmutation not so much because it's
impossible or even unlikely but simply
because the three remaining affinities
fit beyond significantly better but now
we're in a difficult spot because i
think that you can make a solid argument
for enhancement manipulation and
specialization but i'm also going to
drop manipulation out of the running
because on a surface level yes there are
a fair few matches mainly in regards to
patience and apparent value of family
but there is also a big clash with goals
and ambition which leaves us with two
the area with the most evidence is
undoubtedly enhancement hisoka's
personality test doesn't discount the
affinity where it discounts many others
beyond's genetic inheritance supports
enhancement and furykov's criteria also
adds by highlighting the quiet aura of
enhancers however the affinity that fits
the most perfectly is specialization
where there is evidence to question
enhancement there is nothing we've
examined that contradicts specialization
in any way and if we do play the whole
it's a story card then i do think that
specialization is the best dramatic
choice for a primary antagonist and if i
had to place a bet of you know solid
cash monies right now i would probably
go with specialists but enhancement is
also very possible it's difficult to
empirically state one is more likely
than the other so you let me know what
you think in the comments and then go
and have a delightful second video one
which is also about hunter hunter
because there is always more to learn
explore and experience with this
wonderful series so i look forward to
seeing you there